Palestinian refugees trapped in a one
square kilometer World camp in Lebanon
but ainal Helwig also shelters armed
factions that have repeatedly battled
for control and power
the latest truth has been holding for
more than a week but there's no
guarantee the fighting has ended for
good
repairs and reconstruction to an
estimated 400 homes and businesses as
well as facilities run by the United
Nations relief and works agency have not
begun in earnest
staff aren't able to reach half of the
camp to assess the damage particularly a
school complex which was one of the
front lines during the recent violence
reason for that is it is still too
insecure we have armed Fighters
including around our installations
Insider installations apparently as well
one school complex which reportedly has
been violated to hosts over 3 000
children it is very unlikely that these
children will be able to go back to the
school when the school starts in October
un assistance is vital for Palestinians
who are denied Lebanese government
services but the agency has been
struggling with a budget crisis for
years
the agency as a whole does not have a
view on its income Beyond September
so any additional costs that are
incurred through the hostilities when
any damage and humanitarian support will
have to be found in addition to the
money that we already need to run our
regular services
the latest outbreak of violence was the
deadliest in years it involved the
mainstream fatak movement and the group
calling itself the Muslim youth people
in the camp are in many ways held
hostage to the divisions within the
Palestinian leadership there's criticism
of a long-standing agreement that
prevents lebanon's Army from imposing
Law and Order inside the camps but
there's little political will among
lebanon's parties to disarm the factions
those parties are linked to Regional
players who use inter-palestinian
tensions to advance their own agendas
home to tens of thousands of
Palestinians einel Halloween is still
very much a war zone with many fearing
it is not a matter of if but when the
next round of fighting will begin
on the outskirts Southern Lebanon